hey what's up guys my name is a Jenna
and welcome to episode 14 of network
chat programming so today we're gonna
talk all about servers and how to
actually make a server house of it
basically works and how we can make an
interface for our server as well now
unlike you know unlike this client that
we have right now if we launch this
right now what you'll see is is this
login screen of course and if we do
enter a bunch of you know details in
here like the IP address a name and a
host and a port sorry and we login we
get this wonderful thing and whatever we
say appears here oops here okay and all
that stuff works that's this is our user
interface now it's not really that
common to make a user interface for a
server and the reason that there's a few
reasons for that
first of all it's just unnecessary you
know the server's not really going to be
doing too much and out of the stuff that
it will be doing it's just not very
necessary to have an interface for that
so our server is gonna run in the
command line okay and that is a lot of
fun so let's get right into that so in
Cherno chat in this little a folder that
we've got here I'm going to right click
hit new and hit clasp now I'm actually
gonna put this into a separate package
called server okay and I'm gonna do
things a little bit differently because
this is kind of sort of like a mistake
that I made this client Java class
actually contains both the client code
to make the client on the on the network
receive and send data and also the user
interface code and that's usually I'm
not sure why I did that usually what you
would do is you would have all the code
for actually physically sending and
receiving data doing stuff that a client
does so like the logic behind the client
as a separate class and then you have
like a top layer over that an interface
layer like a user interface layer and
that will be a separate class course
another client window or client GUI
so instead of so what I'll do here is I
will create a class called server but
but I'll also create a new class here so
again right-click new class and I'll
call to something like a server main or
something okay I'd call the service
server GUI also
so the window but of course is going to
be command line so server main will do
nicely okay so we've got two classes now
server and server main so what are the
differences server main is going to be
pretty simple okay all that's going to
do is essentially launch a new instance
of the server and you know allow it to
run so this will actually have the main
method that's one of the reasons I
called it main ok so inside our server
class this is going to be of course the
class that actually you know sets up and
and runs the code to send and receive
data here so I'm gonna make a new
private integer here called port and
then I want to make a constructor and
the constructor which is a server of
course the only parameter that will take
is port because of course we don't need
an address we are the address and we
don't need a name because well we're a
servant on the client but of course we
do need a port number because a servic
run on any port pretty much and we need
to specify that port and we'll just said
this to a port equal to port of course
setting this variable equal to the
parameter ok so that's that's it that's
all the code that's going to go into our
server class now server main on the
other hand that of course is the class
that actually runs a server okay it's
the the top layer kind of thing and one
of the reasons it's cool to create a
class like this is because if we put all
of our server related logical code into
this server class what that means is
that we can actually run multiple
servers from this one server main class
ok whereas if we were to do something
like just have one class that wouldn't
be possible right we'd have to actually
run multiple programs of servers so in
other words we have five applicate five
server applications running but with
this we can have one application running
with five servers really cool stuff when
that's not gonna really be useful to us
but it is of course worthy to not so
we'll start off with the main method
okay
the server is its own application of
course so public static void main string
args now I get a pretty common question
actually what is this what is this array
of strings here that we put into the
parameter and it's your lucky day
because we're actually going to be
utilizing that now to understand how
this works
I'm going to probably wish I was on
Windows because it's a lot easier to
explain why is it more people what I
said it but we have this little thing
called a terminal okay and the terminal
on Windows is a command prompt okay that
is the closest you can get to a terminal
it still don't really a terminal but
it's it's close so what this does is it
it's basically you know the opposite of
a GUI so we have this GUI that allows us
to run programs create folders remove
folders rename folders copy files you
know run applications is the big one
usually and we also have this we also
have this this terminal right and back
in the day back in like Windows you know
das and stuff like that or ms-dos I
guess it was called Microsoft DOS
Microsoft disk operating system this
isn't gonna be a computer history lesson
month away but the point is back in the
day this is all you had even have GUI is
okay so our server is gonna run in an in
an environment like this and one of the
reasons that's incredibly useful is
because you actually be able to run this
on you know a a VPS base their virtual
private server you'll be able to run
this on a server that is um you know
maybe you you can like buy a server
which I will do by the way Elam I'll
demonstrate this eventually but
basically what you can do is you can you
know how there's web hosting well
there's also VPS hosting and instead of
actually buying like a web server you
can just well rather renting a web
server you can rent a an actual computer
essentially with a command line like
this usually running a either Windows
server or Linux now you'll most likely
if you connect by as SSH or something
like that rather than a remote desktop
environment what you'll get is a command
line and this makes it basically
impossible to run G or why programs
however of course console based programs
will work so if we were to run something
we in Java at least you know we can do
some cool stuff here like Java version
they'll tell us the version and you know
other stuff if we just type in Java it
will give us the usages so what we want
to do is essentially when we run our
application we want to be able to type
in let me just clear this we want to be
able to type in something like Java and
then of
what's the name of our service at
Renault chat server dot jar that is
actually how we will run our application
okay you type in Java and then the name
of the jar file that you want to run
okay
now now that you've done that we
actually want to hit spacebar and say ok
we want to start this server on port a
one-line - just like that ok after this
now how do we keep how do we the cool
thing about terminals is after you've
typed the name of the application you
won't run you can give it some arguments
ok these kind of like parameters that
you can actually pass into the
application so for us we want to do the
port right because the port we want to
we want essentially we want the user to
be able to set the port when he's
starting a server if we hard code it you
know what if that port is not available
or what if we want to start multiple
Cherno chat servers here we can't
because if it's if we bind it here to be
like you know 8 1 9 - then that's the
only port that can be used the code
actually needs to get altered and
recompiled to get a different port
whereas over here this gives us the
flexibility to actually enter a port in
- at runtime and it will it will
function from that so how do we do that
well that that's where this arcs
variable comes in ok as you might be
imagining right now ox is an array of
strings ok and that array of strings is
equal to however many parameters we
decide to put after this so if we do
something like this the length of this
ogz arrival before it'll contain four
strings a 1 9 2 23 hey and 2 if we put
in just at one line - the length will be
1 and this is the only value will
contain so that is great so let's
actually you know how do we utilize it
well we'll add you ask it's really
simple we can it's again it's just an
array of strengths so the first thing we
want to tell the user is to say well if
you don't you know if you don't supply
an argument that could that could be a
problem could okay we might not want to
make it a problem but it could be a
problem
so but of course if they specify more
than one argument so if someone decides
to go something like a 1 on 2 and then 4
for some weird reason that is wrong and
we want to be able to
handle that so usually the way that I
like to roll is if if args dot length is
greater than one so if there's more than
one in there then we really do need to
system dot out dot print line you know
the usage so actually this is good and
it's in fact his java jar not a java so
this is the way you were on this that's
if you're on a separate class files you
can just use Java
but Java Java is required for Java files
my bad but yeah okay so that so if it is
greater than once if we went to somewhat
something like this we'll get a usage
here Java JA you know Cherno chat server
dojo I guess like I'm not sure what
we'll call it I'm not sure you might not
even need the gel file here but we'll
say and then I guess we'll go port
because it's a it's not required okay
and then we'll return so we weren't on
the program this probably won't make a
heap of sense but if I do set this
something to if it doesn't equal one so
in other words you need you need to have
a port number here and I run this right
what you'll see straight away is eclipse
will tell us I'm over here in the
console the thing that we just printed
okay and the reason is in Eclipse
we of course when we ran this we did not
specify any command line arguments this
is gonna be pretty long tutorial
actually command line arguments is a not
the easiest thing to explain but it does
I ate a some very very powerful and very
useful to know anyway we'll create a new
constructor here quickly called
seven-man and that'll take a probably
one parameter which will be the port
here now the other thing we should do is
create a port integer here okay and what
we'll do is we'll try to set port equal
to integer dot parse int and then our
string which is args 0 okay so now we've
got port and when we actually create our
server man we just want to launch server
main with the port port okay and what
that will do is then set the private int
port that will then set this dot port
equal to port ok so what we've done now
is we've actually taken an input from
the user
and we've assigned it to a variable here
which is very very cool
now just to UM just I'm just thinking if
I should actually make port mandatory or
not probably not we could have a we
could okay I'm just gonna just for the
sake of this of this tutorial I am going
to leave port as a mandatory field so
you have to use port okay that's
actually required and the reason I'm
doing that is just because I'm doing
that because it'll help illustrate the
command line argument a bit better but
what you could do is you could have a
default value so in other words if
arguments.length is equal to zero so in
other words if nothing if no parameters
are given then set the port equal to a
default port such as a 1 1 2 otherwise
you can customize it if you like but
that will work as well okay so how do we
actually run this in Eclipse then we've
made a little program that we can't
actually run in the clips because what
we get here is a usage problem here
right usage Java jar you know chanchad
serve it a shot because arguments of
length is indeed not 1 how do we how do
we do how do we go around that so what
you can do is under the bug because
that's the button but we pressed on this
there's this awesome little menu or this
yeah I guess is this option here called
debug configurations if you click on
that it will open this this window here
now there is a tab called arguments and
program arguments and this is where we
can specify any arguments that we want
so we can just type in 8:1 Munter just
like that and apply that of course and
hit close and then if we run this let's
just to illustrate this let's just print
out port ok so if we run this now what
you'll get in the console is the port
that we entered in the command-line
arguments if we go back to this debug
configuration and change the port number
to eight eight eight eight for example
apply that and close that eight is my
favorite number by the way and if we run
this then in the console we'll get that
okay so we're simulating passing in
command-line arguments here so that is
that is pretty much how command-line
arguments work and how we're going to
use them to give
user more control over how the server's
launched so I hope you did enjoy this
episode of network chat programming if
you did please hit like button again if
this video reaches 200 likes
within 24 hours pretty much then I will
release the video tomorrow if it reaches
300 likes within 24 hours then I will
release two videos tomorrow okay
so again it's up to you guys how fast we
want this series so um
but either way guys hope you enjoyed
this episode of network chat programming
and I'll see you guys next episode good
bye